let's now get to defining woke here is
Nikki Haley also running for the 2022
2024 presidential uh Republican
Presidential nomination she got herself
a nice little CNN Town Hall she was
asked to Define woke it did not go well
Define woke there's a lot of things I
mean you want to start with Bob
on girl Sports
and thing the
Ferry now I mean all of these things
that are pushing what a small minority
want on the majority of Americans it's
too much it's too much I mean the idea
that we have biological boys playing in
girls Sports it is the women's issue of
our time is it my daughter ran track in
high school I don't even know how I
would have that conversation with her
how are we supposed to get our girls
used to the fact that biological boys
are in their locker rooms okay so she
goes off the rails asked to Define woke
she says woke is stuff like biological
Boys in girls locker rooms now she's not
certainly not defining it she's giving
examples of things she believes are woke
it's sort of like if I said hey can you
define what a fruit is and you go well
you know you've got your banana
uh you've got your
you've got your cantaloupe right but
what's the definition of fruit and we
would say oh well the fruit is the seed
bearing structure in a flowering plant
formed from the ovary after flowering
now it's true that sometimes examples
might be more illustrative than some
kind of definition but these are the
people who say if you can't Define woman
there's something wrong with you here
was Ron DeSantis given an attempt to
given the opportunity to Define woke
just a few days ago we know what is it's
a form of cultural Marxism it's about
putting Merit and achievement behind
identity politics and it's basically a
war on the truth and is that as an
infected institution that has corrupted
a lot of Institutions so you've got to
be willing to fight the woke we've done
it in Florida okay so cultural Marxism
was desantis's answer so a couple
different things the term woke has been
perverted I don't know anyone on the
left who still uses it seriously because
it's been perverted it now just
basically means anything right-wingers
don't like what woke meant before it was
perverted meant I am aware of problems
in society that might be bigger than one
person we might call them structural
problems and I think it would be a nice
thing to fix those problems that was
wokeness when the term was used
seriously they've now totally perverted
it cultural Marxism was desantis's
attempt to Define cultural Marxism is a
far-right anti-semitic conspiracy theory
that blames Jewish German academics
known as the Frankfurt School for
spreading movements like identity
politics and political correctness as
some kind of way to manipulate and
undermine western civilization and
Christian values that's what cultural
Marxism is it also
it uses the word Marxism
so it makes it sound like it's somehow
related to Marx but it's not it's a
misnomer it has nothing to do with the
economic and class analysis of Karl Marx
it also really misrepresents the ideas
of the frankfur Frankfurt School as well
like him or hate him the Frankfurt
School were a group of critical
theorists who analyzed the role of
culture and mass media and ideology in
society so cultural Marxism is like a
post-factual dog whistle appealing to
anti-Semitism and paranoia that's how
that's how DeSantis is defining woke
this is actually going to be a bigger
issue than we might think
because the longer that they continue
using woke in this way
the more it is going to seem like an
actual platform or proposal when it's
not it's a misunderstood talking point
that they don't even understand so we'll
get back to it in the coming days Nikki
Haley swinging a miss and certainly
striking out Ron DeSantis one of our
sponsors today is wild Health founded by
two Emergency Room Physicians wild
Health takes your genetics and your
Biometrics and your lifestyle data to
really tailor suggestions to your exact
needs in terms of nutrition and exercise
and sleep and supplements and all of
those things and the whole idea is just
for you to function at your best it's
really a quite it's a simple goal but
it's a complex goal to achieve you might
have a specific Health goal you want to
sleep better you want to lose weight you
want to stay healthy and just feel good
wild health will tailor a care plan with
lifestyle intervention instead of
medications which I prefer as an
approach wild health will pair you with
a care team that includes a
board-certified Precision medicine
physician and accredited health coach
who can receive messages from you
anytime through the app it's fully
virtual telemedicine and if you're
really trying to reach your top physical
and mental condition try wild Health's
premium program at wildhealth.com
premium which includes the white glove
concierge service unlimited visits even
higher touch care these results are
really compelling patients have seen
improvements to diabetic markers reduced
risk of cardiovascular disease reduction
in inflammation and more go to
wildhealth.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 20 off the link is down below